- But your family is from Jamaica.
- Yes.
- I love Jamaica.
So I heard while you were there-
- Love Jamaica.
Who loves Jamaica?
- Who doesn't love Jamaica?
(audience cheering)
It's like one of those places
you go and you're like,
"People live here."
When we go on vacation,
it's like, this is when
you start questioning
your life decisions and
why you aren't living
in a certain place.
But it's beautiful there.
But I heard that you ran into
the legendary Grace Jones there.
- Oh my God, yes.
- That's incredible.
First of all, just you
two in the same room.
I don't know if there's enough,
that's a lot of powerful energy happening.
- First of all, I love Grace Jones.
I'm obsessed with her.
- [Kelly] Who doesn't?
- She's incredible and then secondly,
so Grace Jones is from Spanish Town
which is where my mother's from.
So I'm convinced that we're related
and when I met Grace, she was
like, "We could be sisters."
And I'm like, "Oh, Grace."
- I agree.
- You see it too, Grace?
- [Kelly] You see it too.
I heard that, did y'all end up dancing?
- Yes, we danced love all night together
because she's a partier.
I love her.
She loves to dance and I love to dance
and I was like, "Oh my God,
"I want to dance floor with Grace Jones."
- That's a win in life.